boy this large prostate situation
is extremely common
as the man ages one out of two that's 50
will get an enlarged prostate
and this is called benign prostatic
hyperplasia
which basically means an enlarged
prostate now before i get into what to
do because this is actually
not a terribly complex problem if you
understand it
and also there's a great solution which
i'm going to get to but i want to just
first differentiate
what is the difference between bph and
cancer of the prostate
are they similar
they're not too similar in fact they're
pretty different in cancer you have
these normal cells that then get damaged
specifically the mitochondria and then
they switch over to cancer cells okay
and so with prostate cancer that can
spread through the body
and it can kill you it's very deadly but
with bph
it's benign which means it's not going
to spread it's not going to turn into
cancer it is not deadly now with the
symptoms of prostate cancer you're going
to get blood in the urine you're gonna
get blood in the semen you're gonna have
painful urination you're gonna have a
difficult time with an erection you may
have pain with ejaculation and so the
symptoms are are very different than bph
where really this involves just the
urinary tract mostly you're going to get
up to the night and want to urinate you
may have the urge to urinate but can't
urinate or you can't fully eliminate the
bladder so it's a bit incomplete so with
bph you just have a lot of different
urination issues simply because the
prostate is a gland and it wraps around
the urethra which is a little tube from
your urinary bladder
that comes out through your penis and as
the prostate enlarges it obstructs the
tube
and you're not able to fully eliminate
freely all the urine that's supposed to
come out through the urinary bladder so
you're going to start and stop and start
and stop and have dribbling and all
sorts of issues but the prostate should
only be the size of a walnut but it can
actually get quite large now with the
prostate cancer a big question is
will
phytonutrients specifically
phytoestrogens make things worse
there are certain compounds in
herbs
and vegetables
that mimic estrogens okay they're called
phytoestrogens and we know estrogen
dominance in general can cause
cancer in women breast cancer and also
men as well and a lot of the chemicals
in the environment mimic estrogen like
the pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides heavy metals they're all
considered estrogen disruptors or
endocrine disruptors but when we get to
plant-based estrogens like
phytoestrogens
there's a couple things you need to know
with phytoestrogens you can prevent
prostate cancer you can slow down the
progression
if you have prostate cancer
in the early stages but if you're in a
stage of three or four or more you may
want to hesitate because there is some
data that these
phytoestrogens can actually make things
worse but i want to make a side note
the studies that i read on this were
relating to castrated males so
if someone's castrated and they have
advanced stages of cancer they should
not consume
any phytoestrogens even in small amounts
because it can make things worse however
the purpose of this video is to focus
more on enlarged prostate so let's talk
about that so there's two main
theories about why
men
develop
a benign prostatic hyperplasia and based
on all the data that i've read i think
both of these series are true and they
both work together the first theory has
to do with
as a man ages okay
their testosterone goes down and both
men and women have both testosterone and
estrogen and so as a man ages as their
testosterone goes down their estrogen
goes up in relationship so they have
this ratio of lowered
testosterone and higher
estrogen that's what occurs with aging
and if anything can be said about bph
it is that it's involved with aging
factors of aging so number one we have
lower testosterone and higher levels of
estrogen and estrogen makes things grow
especially the prostate estrogen also
can cause your pituitary
to trigger another hormone
called prolactin that can also enlarge
the prostate as one ages many times they
gain more weight they have more fat and
the more fat you have the more estrogen
you're going to have to because there's
a certain enzyme that will convert your
testosterone to
estrogen and that enzyme is called
aromatase and this happens in both men
and women and if your liver is in damage
let's say it's inflamed let's say you
have a fatty liver or you have cirrhosis
scar tissue the liver you're going to
generate more estrogen i'm sorry to have
to tell you this if you like to drink
beer
but alcohol especially beer
will affect the liver in that you're
going to raise your estrogen levels
a lot higher than your testosterone so
alcohol in general lower your
testosterone and raise your estrogen
okay the other thing that i want to
mention and this is this is important to
understand there's three types of
estrogen okay
you got estrogen one
two and three and these estrogens out
there they kind of connect to these
little receptors okay in different parts
of the body
it's only the estrogen ii
that can enlarge the prostate not
estrogen one or estrogen three
and all those phytoestrogens those
plant-based compounds that affect
estrogen only affect estrogen number one
not two not three so phytoestrogens do
not enlarge a prostate however
they do attempt to go into the receptors
in estrogen ii
and end up blocking them so other types
of estrogen cannot create the effect
so they help lower the estrogen too
which indirectly protects you against
this prostate enlargement problem so
when you hear all this information out
there about
plant-based estrogens
enlarging your prostate it's absolutely
not true it's not going to happen all
right the second part of this puzzle
involves testosterone as your
testosterone decreases
you also have
a powerful form of testosterone called
dht okay that increases
dhc is responsible for hair loss it's
also responsible for the enlargement of
your prostate so as you age
you have lower testosterone and higher
levels of dht
those people that have genetic problems
where they can't make dht
never develop in a large prostate
so the question is
what's making more of this dht
well this relates to another enzyme okay
the name of that enzyme is called
5-alpha reductase and if you have too
much of that enzyme you're going to get
too much dht and that could potentially
enlarge your prostate all right so now
that you know both mechanisms uh what
can we do about it okay well the first
strategy
is to start consuming more
phytoestrogens okay that's going to help
you and there's a real common one called
genenstein that a lot of people take for
an enlarged prostate and genisan is a
phytoestrogen that's in a lot of legumes
it's in a lot of different things that
can help with this enlarged prostate uh
the next thing is cruciferous vegetables
kale broccoli brussels sprouts
cabbage all increase the amount of
phytoestrogens in the body so you should
start eating those foods on a regular
basis they will not increase the
estrogen number two they'll block it to
prevent other things from entering into
that receptor
that can cause enlarged prostate now the
next two strategies involving blocking
those two enzymes
one of the enzymes called aromatase and
that's the one that converts
testosterone into estrogen okay and
that's in your fat cells it's in other
cells and so you want to take aromatase
inhibitors okay
now certain medications for the prostate
do it synthetically i recommend doing
the natural versions of that and believe
it or not i released a video recently
by blending the entire lemon the lemon
peel the white part the seeds everything
every morning with some stevia and you
blend it in some water and drink that
apparently citrus peels okay from lemons
and limes
can act as an aromatase inhibitor so if
you haven't seen that video i put it
down below it's a real easy thing to do
and it'll also give you a lot of vitamin
c and other things as well another
really powerful aromatase inhibitor is
stinging nettle root i like stinging
nettle root a lot because it's a great
anti-inflammatory as well so if you have
arthritis definitely want to take that
one and then the other one is dim okay
dim is a concentrated
cruciferous compound
that you can take as a supplement and
greatly help
in the balance of excessive amounts of
estrogen and then the third category is
to block the other enzyme called 5-alpha
reductase and so you want to inhibit
that enzyme and that would be by taking
saw palmetto which you probably already
heard that's good for the prostate also
pumpkin seeds will help reduce that
enzyme and green tea will reduce that
enzyme and zinc will help produce that
enzyme so now you know why it works
but on the flip side you also want to
avoid certain things too
high levels of insulin
can act as a
growth factor for your prostate so you
definitely need to go low carb
as well as doing intermittent fasting i
would also
avoid dairy products because dairy has
some estrogenic compounds and you may
have already connected the dots between
times that you
for supper had more dairy and then that
night you're getting up having more
urination problems or having problems
avoiding so dairy is a is a factor uh
then we have alcohol okay if you want a
good alternative for alcohol i would um
try kombucha tea it's similar in texture
to beer and it gives you a nice
relaxation effect now the other point i
want to bring up is plastics i've done a
whole video on this but unfortunately
the plastics in our environment
are mimicking estrogen and creating some
serious problems especially with an
enlarged prostate an average person in
the u.s consumes the amount of
nano plastics that would equal the size
of a credit card
so i do have a video on that and i put
that down below as well
if you're drinking water and without a
filter like tap water you're going to be
getting a lot of compounds that mimic
estrogen as well
especially those plastics so you want to
get a water filter for your house and
then you have the hormones and the foods
right so if you're not consuming
many organic foods and you eat out at a
fast food restaurant
you're getting a lot of hormones that
are coming from the animal products that
are being mimicked from the pesticides
herbicides fungicides things like that
now as a really simple thing that you
can do
right off the bat
is to start including
whole lemons okay in the blender with
water
every time you get up in the morning if
you haven't seen that video i'm going to
put it up right here check it out